elle répète et répète sans arrêt pour
que chaque geste et déplacements
devienne un automatisme
avant même de se mettre à l'eau c'est ce
que l'on appelle une répétition à sec
les nageuses de faire preuve de
concentration et d'élégance
mais pas seulement car avant d'être
renommé artistique
cette natation là est avant tout dit
synchronisée
[Musique]
c'est important en fait d'être d'avoir
des mouvements propres parce qu'il
suffit qu'il y ait une fille tout
simplement qu'il rajoute un petit
mouvement parasite pour que sa fausse
tout on va penser à tellement de choses
en même temps que c'est la chorégraphie
ça doit c'est quelque chose qui va
devenir automatique
la discipline est exigeante elle réclame
autant de grâce que d'énergie musculaire
et de puissance
et côté compétition la concurrence est
de plus en plus rude avec un système de
notation plus sévères étaient pas mac
cela n'était pas un max de la haute
céline vous êtes toujours exigeante
comme ça oui il faut il faut parce que
parce que le niveau augmente de chaque
année chez nos adversaires
donc il faut qu'on monte aussi vite
voire plus vite tant que oui on est très
précis en est très pointilleux et les
filles doivent aussi être exigeante avec
elle même qualité d'exécution
difficultés des mouvements chorégraphie
et interprétation musicale tout est noté
malgré un travail en apnée et avec
l'interdiction de toucher ou de cd du
fond de la piscine
les nageuses doivent exceller dans leur
capacité de propulsion on est moins
pointilleux sur l'extension parce que
c'est quelque chose qu'elles ont déjà
l'extension de jambes le fait d'avoir
une ligne de jambes très belle le jeune
autret rentrée par contre on va assister
sur tout ce qui est auteur parce
qu'enfin ce cordeau mais l'intérêt c'est
d'être le plus haut possible au dessus
de l'eau on va on va insister sur le
placement des bras sous l'eau ils
permettent aux jambes de sortir plus
possible c'est très fatigant c'est très
épuisant ça demande de faire des
allers-retours en haut en bas avec les
bras mais mais c'est ce qui fait que ça
monte ça descend que ça fait des effets
artistiques avec pour premier objectif
se distinguer au carifta games à barbade
parmi les meilleurs jeunes de la caraïbe
les carifta on a l'espoir d'avoir une
médaille et on veut gagner
on va se donner les moyens de gagner ou
d'abord n'importe quelle médaille
tamponnais sur le podium parce qu'on a
travaillé pour ça et c'est notre
objectif
un objectif qu'elle chercheront à
atteindre sur des prestations en solo et
en duo
[Musique]